are we scared senseless because the bad
news is relentless
psychologists have confirmed that yeah
the pandemic the economy the war in
ukraine the mcrib not being available
all year have definitely messed with our
heads
the american psychological association
or epay
[Laughter]
published a wide-ranging annual uh
stress in america survey which was a
real pain in the ass to fill out by the
way
but they found out that 87 of americans
feel like there's been a constant stream
of crises during the past two years
thanks joe biden or obama or obama biden
michelle
and more than 75 feel overwhelmed by it
the remaining 27 were too freaked out to
finish the survey
that means almost everyone you pass by
on the street could be on the verge of a
meltdown and punching you in the face at
any moment especially if her initials
are dana perrino
and it's true people are losing their
minds if by people you mean idiots like
new york times columnist paul krugman
who predicts violence towards mask
wearers after the mask mandate was
dropped
if only there was someone to pull us out
of this what should we do about this mr
president
hey hey
come on man look look i understand
people are stressed out i understand it
and it but i told you what it was about
right there's two reasons for it all
right
vladimir kovet
putin 19.
both those guys and
look
old joe i know how to deal with this
thing all right i know what it feels
like when you have to put food in your
gas tank all right so
you got to listen to people though you
got to do what you're told if people
would do what they're told then we
wouldn't have to take off our shoes when
we went into the bus station then
they on the airport the uh the the on
the on the uh the thing there
you know uh the president makes an
interesting point tyrus
a lot of stress is driven by people
meddling in other people's lives we used
to have a community and now it's like a
reverse community instead of people
helping you like your neighbors or that
you could borrow lawn tools now it's
like other people you don't know telling
you how to lead your life well
there's
there's real problems and then there's
first world problems and first world
problems seem to be the where it's
anything you know like oh i'm worried
about how many pieces of paper go into
your books each year greg yes how many
trees are you murdering murderous
bastard and you know that's and i can't
sleep at night thinking about that's not
a real problem yeah sounds good it's
virtue signaling
real problems is like how am i going to
pay my bills this week yeah what
problems is my kid run away from school
or i'm dealing with family drug
addiction those are real problems that
americans deal with and still find ways
to make their lives work and go right
they're not doing the survey
it's the it's the ones in the safe
spaces who are like so upset because
somebody said the f word on tv and they
need to go down or i know you said
something in 1981 you know we got to
find it you know and that's
that's what's taking the place of what
problems are like these fake problems
because the virtue signaling is the new
is the new thing to do will be on tv
because you get a lot of attention for
it and you have severe
ptsd severe greg i do severe severe you
know um cat what i've noticed is that i
do believe the masked is a new identity
it's going to be because now because if
krugman says that you could be
victimized that's a victim class we
might have like masked hate crimes you
know
yes probably
like unmasked maggot supporters yeah
putting a noose around your neck cat for
wearing a mask yeah i do
i don't know does he actually believe
that that's true or not and i don't know
which one is worse
because i don't i really don't think
that's gonna happen yeah i mean if i i
still when i see people like still in
new york there's people outside yes who
wear masks and
i generally i mean maybe they have some
sort of medical condition i generally do
assume that you're stupid but i'm not
gonna hit you no okay nobody's i don't
think people are gonna be beating people
up because they want to wear masks i
just don't want someone to force me to
wear a mask and it's been so fun for
them for so many years to have all these
options
oh you went out and that makes you a bad
person oh i wear this match my face so
i'm a better person you usually have to
put in more effort
to have people think you're a good
person but here you don't and i think
that's what they're mourning more than a
mask is the mask the new western burqa
wow wow thank you
these are big ideas from you i know you
know
i'm pretty impressed i uh i think that
you
when you decide that your personal
liberty and other people's personal
liberty are important your life gets so
much better you don't have to worry
about what other people are doing you
don't have to worry about what they're
how they're raising their kids you don't
have to worry about whether they're
wearing a mask or not you've got so much
more free time to enjoy your life yeah
but it is true i feel like there has
been this two years of stress and i
think it's been a difficult actually
difficult century to be honest with a
lot of things going on right um that we
should probably all decide to do the
healthy thing which is to take all those
feelings and bottle them up and stick
them in a very secret place and pretend
none of it ever happened you know
i i'm not supposed to say this but to
solve the solution is drugs probably
mushrooms
say mushrooms legal mushrooms would
probably solve all this you know what's
interesting we talk about the stress the
study comes out you know what's missing
from this all this stress trump i
thought trump was the thing causing all
the stress that is a great point and
he's gone he's not around he's he's not
tweeting and yet we have all this stress
i blame it on the damn liberals
that's the could be the title of my new
book those damn liberals and i'm gonna
be like this
[Laughter]
well they got addicted to the stress and
they had to replace that yeah exactly
you know yeah i wonder all the stress is
coming from also we gave busy bodies the
the rule of the land for the last few
years and suddenly it's like they're
stressed out that they can't make you
wear the mask on the airplane and
they're stressed out that you're
standing too close to them and they
can't control you anymore yes these poor
things i find it i i i really do think
there's something wrong with maskers but
i've come to pieces there i find it
entertaining now when i encounter one on
the street i'm like look a massacre
imagine what they believe this is
hilarious yes you know it's it's so it's
but it is going to they it's not like
we're creating the identity for them
they're embracing the identity it is
going to be part of the liberal
component that makes up the mosaic of
liberal life whether you're pro-choice
gun control math right because they
could just wear the mask rather than
what so many of them are doing is
wearing the mask and now the pictures
are back on twitter yeah yeah yeah i'm
still wearing my mask on the plane
that's great that's it go ahead this is
a great benefit for us yeah wear the
mask
easiest possible solution yes don't pass
any laws i just don't care enough about
people to give a damn whether they have
a hat on a mask on i mean just wear
shirt and shoes please i mean that's i
don't know and pants yeah pants i don't
i'm tall so i don't look you need to
specify with this yes and pants
and pants thank you thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else